well joining me to discuss this is
Junior smart who's the founder of SOS
project at St Giles trust an
organization which works with young
people who are at risk of being
exploited through gangs and violence a
very good morning to you thank you for
joining us
now this report makes for very Stark
reading uh today that it is now the norm
for children as young as nine years old
to run drugs for gangs in England is
that really the case is it that
prevalent
yeah definitely we've certainly seen an
increase in young people being groomed I
think we had a we had a lot of things
that was happening at the same time so
for example you had covid and which
meant that a lot more people were being
isolated therefore a lot more young
people
um were going online and they you know
unfortunately the way that these groups
are recruiting now they have embraced
technology in a way that many of the
statutory Services have been slow to
keep up so you know we've certainly seen
and we've certainly every incidence of
violence there has been an online
presence both before and afterwards
we've seen these organized criminal
groups
um putting out messages attracting
grooming young people through online
sources and then coupled that with the
austerity and the cost of the living
crisis what you've got is a lack of
availability of choice for many families
that were already he's suffering
um and what happens to those households
where the adults have to work more hours
unfortunately there's less of a parental
presence and so young people have been
more likely to be attracted and groomed
into these to these negative cycles and
and that part of it is very common I
think as far as the ages are concerned
none of us should really be surprised
how how often is it that you've worked
we've worked with someone and we've said
well actually we should have put in an
intervention perhaps even before that
child was even born so really the key
thing here is how can we get to these
young people earlier how can we put in
preventative measures to stop young
people being groomed and being exploited
and falling into these negative traps
and and you have a first-hand experience
um I read your bio last night where you
describe how a combination of negative
choices uh led to you being sentenced to
12 years in prison originally for a
drug-related offense
um what would have helped you what would
have potentially been what would you
like to have seen there to have caught
you from some of those negative choices
well for me one of the key things that
was missing was the lack of uh positive
role models somebody that I could relate
to
um and that's exactly what we're trying
to do now through SOS and SOS plus so
through our services we use people with
lived experience people that have got
first-hand experience of the realities
that these young people are facing and
then for example for SMS plus we're
going into schools colleges community
centers people with verbal units and
really trying to impart real tools that
the young people can use straight away
in order to make better lifestyle
choices you know one of the key things
here is relatability how many people do
you see in positions of authority that
the young people can relate to and
that's exactly what we're trying to to
get at when we go into the schools and
we open up a clear space and we're
asking young people what do you know
about this what do you know about County
Lions what do you know about this and I
realize it's a safe space Oh my gosh
they start asking us questions they want
to know what the reality is and that
gives us a really strong Edge to get
across to the young people what to do
better the traps they need to avoid and
also who they can trust who they can
turn to in in these situations young
people are faced with a marriage of
information and misinformation and I
really do feel sorry for the young
people now because they're over enforced
and under protected
um and we need to be better at how we
serve and support them
and it's not just about county lines
where children are drawn into running
drugs for for older gangs
um young people around the country uh
often from deprived areas are drawn to
gangs in general uh there's high crime
uh some carry weapons uh some some die
uh during these kind of gang feuds what
needs to be done to lift young people
out of that
oh wow that's a massive question I think
the solutions are going to be very very
complex if you look at the
um figures
often we're working with people that are
both victims and perpetrators so the
same person who might be carrying a
knife today for protection they could
have been a victim two weeks ago now the
reality of this is how much of that
victim element is actually taken into
account at the point of arrest the
problem is with many of the services
that are overstretched and
under-resourced which all leads to quick
fixes and
um improper Solutions at the point of
arrest where a young person has been say
for example caught with a knife or
caught with drugs they are treated
purely and simply as a perpetrator none
of the other factors you know we know
for example these groups
um capture these kids through things
like debt bondage so that drugs that
will be confiscated and that kid will be
arrested for that will create a debt
that doesn't that means that that kid
isn't going to get away with it that
means that kid is now going to have to
work for free and all that's happening
is we're treating what we see as as the
as the symptom actually as a cause at
that point rather than taking into
account all of the other factors and
this makes the situation worse what that
that young person often needs is support
what that young person often needs
um is support for their family they
might um need that guidance at that at
that lowest point to get out and and
that's just not being addressed and we
just see the same thing with school
exclusions I think that came up in the
report and we know that school
exclusions is a massive link to to the
negative cycle that leads to criminal
behavior and we need to be better
um you know we need to be better as a
society the government needs to address
the underlying issues here more because
they're the sort of things that create
this negative cycle that mean that
problems like this will not go away
Junior smart we really appreciate your
thoughts and insight thank you so much
for joining us and best of luck with
your work thank you so much